l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion
deuxième lecture du projet de loi adopté
avec modifications par l'assemblée
nationale relative à l'immigration à
l'intégration et à la nationalité
dans la discussion générale la parole
est à monsieur claude guéant ministre de
l'intérieur de l'outre-mer des
collectivités territoriales et de
l'immigration
madame la présidente je présidents des
commissions des lois monsieur le
rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
heures
il y un peu plus de 20 ans avec la chute
du mur de berlin l'est de l'europe
s'ouvrait à la démocratie aujourd'hui
c'est au tour des pays du sud de la
méditerranée de s'engager
courageusement sur cette voie face à
cette situation nous pourrions c'est
vrai nous contenter d'une posture
d'observateurs passif nous devons bien
au contraire et je sais que vous en êtes
comme moi convaincu adopter une attitude
responsable
être responsable c'est bien sûr apporter
tout notre soutien à l'avènement de ce
nouveau régime
être responsable c'est aussi faire face
avec réalisme aux conséquences de ces
bouleversements et en particulier à la
pression migratoire qu'ils engendrent en
direction de l'europe c'est aussi notre
devoir vis-à-vis de nos voisins
méditerranéens qui ont aujourd'hui plus
que jamais besoin de toutes leurs forces
vives pour se construire dans ce
contexte d'espoir et de bouleversements
le projet de loi relatif à l'immigration
à l'intégration et à la nationalité que
je reviens vous présentez prend donc une
résonance toute particulière
il constitue une occasion de traiter
avec pragmatisme notamment la question
de l'immigration clandestine
nous devons saisir cette occasion avec
résolution et rapidité
qui est entièrement tourné vers
l'efficacité républicaine concrètes
exclusivement opérationnel ces
dispositions sont indispensables et
attendu par les services qui se chargent
jour après jour de lutter contre
l'immigration clandestine
rapidement pour permettre la
transposition intégrale de la directive
communautaire retour en droit français
et mettre fin à son application
partielle consécutive à la mi à l'avis
émis par le conseil d'état le 21 mars
dernier
nous avons pris sur la transposition de
cette directive
le temps du débat parlementaire et donc
de la réflexion démocratique nous
pourrons passer à l'action
la qualité du travail fourni par votre
commission des lois et tout particulier
par son président jean jacques hyest et
son rapporteur françois noël buffet on
est un bon augure les travaux
préparatoires ont en effet permis
d'opérer avec succès plusieurs
rapprochements importants entre la
position du gouvernement et la
sensibilité propre de la haute assemblée
permettez-moi d'abord de vous rappeler
les grandes priorités de notre politique
d'immigration ses priorités découle tout
simplement des deux grands principes qui
fondent depuis 2007 notre politique
d'immigration
premier principe tout étranger en
situation irrégulière a vocation à être
reconduit dans son pays
sauf situations particulières deuxième
principe un étranger qui est accueillie
légalement sur notre territoire doit
être bien accueillie
c'est le sens que nous donnons au
concept d'intégration
ces priorités se traduisent concrètement
chaque année par des résultats que le
gouvernement à coeur de vous transmettre
vous disposez ainsi depuis quelques
jours du septième rapport au parlement
sur les orientations de la politique
migratoire au terme d'un travail
minutieux d'agrégation des données ce
document fait notamment ressortir pour
l'année 2009 une baisse du regroupement
familial de 12 % une baisse de
l'immigration professionnelle qui durait
c'est probablement lié à la crise
économie de 10% et une hausse de
l'immigration étudiante
mais plutôt que de vous faire un exposé
sur des données dont vous disposez déjà
je préfère mettre en valeur les
priorités du gouvernement
la première de ses priorités c'est la
lutte contre l'immigration irrégulière
vous le savez depuis 2007 ce sont plus
de cent dix mille personnes qui ont été
éloignés vers leur pays d'origine et
plus de 100 2000 qui ont été refoulés à
la frontière grâce à la loppsi entre en
vigueur le 15 mars dernier
nous disposons désormais d'un cadre
juridique claire et fiable pour les
contrôles d'initiatives dans la bande
frontalière des 20 km ainsi que dans les
ports gares et aéroports ouverts au
trafic international
je souhaite par ailleurs que nous
assurions de la sécurité juridique de
nos procédures d'éloignement
c'est pourquoi sur ma suggestion le
garde des sceaux a diffusé récemment aux
procureurs généraux
une circulaire incitant les parcs et à
utiliser plus fréquemment leurs pouvoirs
d'appel suspensif des décisions des
juges des libertés et de la détention
même si naturellement chaque affaire
mérite un traitement au cas par cas
cette procédure d'appel est le gage
d'une meilleure régulation juridique des
décisions des jld
le projet de loi soumis à votre examen
facilite d'ailleurs la mise en oeuvre de
cet appel suspensif en accroissant de
deux heures le délai ouvert au parquet
pour l'exercer il nous appartient aussi
de tirer le meilleur parti des
possibilités offertes par la technologie
comme j'ai pu le constater à nantes
visitant la sous-direction des visas le
déploiement des visas biométriques est
désormais une réalité en 2010 50% des
visas délivrés par la france étaient des
visas biométriques
il est tout à fait nécessaire que sur
notre territoire les services de police
et de gendarmerie soit en mesure de
tirer le bénéfice de ses progrès dans la
lutte contre l'immigration irrégulière
c'est pourquoi d'ici le mois de juin 150
postes d'accès à la base de données vise
à bio seront installés dans les services
la situation qui est constatée
actuellement en italie sur l'île de
lampedusa me confortent dans la volonté
de mener avec détermination cette lutte
contre l'immigration irrégulière et les
résultats sont là entre le 23 février et
le 6 avril 1921 ressortissants tunisiens
exactement en situation irrégulière ont
d'ores et déjà été effectivement
éloignés vers la tunisie ou réadmis en
italie ou dans un autre pays européen
l'action que nous menons est strictement
conforme au droit communautaire et aux
conventions bilatérales conclues avec
nos partenaires
al'inverse la france n'accepte pas les
pratiques non coopératives et des
instructions claires ont été données aux
préfets et aux services de police et de
gendarmerie pour que le respect des
règles de schengen soit scrupuleusement
contrôlés je me suis rendue vendredi
dernier à milan pour rencontrer mon
homologue italien nous nous sommes mis
d'accord sur le principe d'une réponse
concertée aux problèmes d'immigration
clandestine que nous rencontrons depuis
plusieurs semaines nous sommes convenus
par exemple d'organiser dans le cadre de
frontex des patrouilles communes au
large des côtes tunisiennes
mais la solution durable contre
l'immigration clandestine se trouve bien
sûr dans un dialogue politique
renouvelée avec les pays d'émigration
nous devons dans le cadre de l'union
européenne apporter toute l'aide
nécessaire aux pays de la rive sud de la
méditerranée qui connaissent aujourd'hui
une nouvelle ère de liberté
nous devons les aider à aborder cette
phase nouvelle de leur développement
économique
mais nous devons aussi les convaincre
que le règlement des questions
migratoires est au coeur du partenariat
que nous souhaitons nouer avec c'est le
message que j'ai porté hier encore à
l'occasion de la réunion des 27
ministres de l'intérieur européens qui
se tenait à luxembourg
notre deuxième priorité c'est la
maîtrise de l'immigration régulière
beaucoup déjà a été fait depuis 2007 le
regroupement familial a été réformé il
ne représente plus que quinze mille
titres de séjour par an contre 25 milles
avant la réforme
parallèlement et vous le verrez en
lisant le rapport au parlement sur les
orientations de la politique
d'immigration
l'immigration professionnelle a
progressé même si comme je vous le
disais tout à l'heure en 2009 les effets
de la crise économique ont été observés
nous devons aujourd'hui nous poser la
question d'une nouvelle étape dans la
maîtrise de l'immigration légale
c'était le sens de mes propos de la
semaine dernière et je ferai dans les
prochains jours des propositions de
réduction du nombre de titres de séjours
délivrés chaque année notre troisième
priorité c'est celle de l'intégration
certains s'interrogent sur les raisons
pour lesquelles le gouvernement tient à
maîtriser les flux migratoires
la raison c'est que nous voulons que
notre pays qui reste fidèle à lui même
fidèle à ses valeurs fidèle à la
république
notre capacité à accueillir n'est pas
sans limite
la france est un pays ouvert un pays
généreux mais si nous voulons éviter les
tensions
les préjugés voire les risques de
xénophobie
il faut que les flux migratoires soit
maîtrisé qu'il reste à la mesure de
notre capacité à les accueillir
depuis 2003 près de cinq cent mille
personnes
ont signé un contrat d'accueil et
d'intégration par lequel elle s'engage à
respecter les principes qui régissent
notre république et à apprendre le
français
je souhaite et le projet de loi va dans
ce sens que nous nous assurions que
chaque étrangers accueillis en france et
à plus forte raison
chaque candidat à la naturalisation
dispose d'un niveau suffisant de
maîtrise de notre langue
j'étais ce matin même dans le val d'oise
avec votre collègue hugues portelli pour
faire le point sur notre politique d'
aide à l'apprentissage du français
j'ai rencontré cette occasion les
responsables associatifs de cette action
je me suis aussi entretenu avec des
migrants qui font cette démarche
d'intégration leurs exemples le prouvent
maîtriser notre langue c'est bien
évidemment trouver plus facilement du
travail et avoir plus de prise sur
l'éducation de ses enfants
enfin notre quatrième priorité est de
garantir la soutenabilité de notre
système d'assise notre tradition
d'accueil des réfugiés politiques et
restera une valeur cardinale défendu et
protégé par le gouvernement ce sont
environ environ dix mille réfugiés
politiques qui sont accueillis chaque
année par la france mais si les
procédures d'asile ont une vocation
accueillir des réfugiés politiques
elles n'ont pas pour objet de contourner
les règles d'entrée en france pour
devenir une filière d'immigration
or nous assistons pourtant depuis deux
ans à une très nette augmentation des
demandes plus 20% en 2008 + 12% en 2009
+ 10 % en 2010 à nouveau nous devons
lutter fermement contre toutes les
formes d'abus
car ces abus portent préjudice en
définitive aux demandeurs de bonne foi
qui mérite la protection de notre pays
face à cela notre stratégie consiste à
tout faire
pour réduire la durée d'instruction des
demandes d'asile cette réduction des
délais est d'abord une garantie pour les
véritables demandeurs d'asile celle
d'obtenir une réponse dans un délai
raisonnable mais elle doit aussi
permettre d'éviter que le temps passant
la demande d'asie ne soit détournée dans
cet esprit dès 2011
nous renforçons les moyens de l'ofpra et
de la cour nationale du droit d'asile
grâce à la loi de finances que vous avez
voté et à des arbitrages complémentaires
intervenues depuis par le premier
ministre ce sont 40 postes qui sont
créés à l'ofpra et 50 à la cour
nationale du droit d'asile
ces moyens supplémentaires doivent
permettre de réduire la durée
d'instruction des demandes d'une moyenne
de 19 mois constaté en 2010 ce qui est
tout à fait excessive à une moyenne
d'environ un an et cela dès la fin de
cette année le projet de loi par
ailleurs apporte des améliorations
procédural qui poursuivent le même
objectif
le projet de loi dont nous débattons
aujourd'hui apporte de nouveaux outils
au service de cette stratégie d'ensemble
le maître mot en et l'efficacité vous
avez déjà examiné le texte en première
lecture
je me limiterai donc un bref rappel de
son contenu
le projet d'abord inscrit dans notre
droit national les innovations que nous
avons promu à l'échelle européenne
concrètement il transpose trois
directives communautaires
je souhaite marc était principalement
sur la directive retour qui donne un
nouveau cadre juridique à notre
politique d'éloignement des étrangers en
situation régulière
ces directives apporte trois innovations
majeures
première innovation la directive retour
pose le strunc le principe du délai de
départ volontaire pour la mise en oeuvre
des mesures d'éloignement
ce délai doit être compris entre 7 et 30
jours nous faisons le choix dont le
projet qui vous est soumis de fixer
cette durée à 30 jours
par cohérence avec le régime actuel des
obligations à quitter le territoire
français
mais ce délai de départ volontaire peut
être refusé si l'étranger concerné
représente une menace pour l'ordre
public
si un titre de séjour lui a déjà été
refusée pour fraude ou encore s'il
existe un risque qu'il tente de se
soustraire à l'exécution de la mesure
d'éloignement
c'est ce que l'on appelle le risque de
fuite ce risque est présumé par exemple
lorsqu'un étranger est entré
irrégulièrement sur le territoire et qui
n'a tenté aucune démarche administrative
pour régulariser sa situation
dans son avis du 21 mars dernier le
conseil d'état a refusé que le risque de
fuite puisse être invoquée par
l'administration tant que le projet de
loi ne serait pas adopté définitivement
vos débats d'aujourd'hui et votre vote
doivent donc permettre de donner toute
sa portée à l'application de la
directive retour
deuxième innovation directive retour
encadre davantage le régime de la
rétention administrative en prévoyant
que celle ci n'est justifiée que
lorsqu'une mesures moins coercitives ne
suffirait pas c'est pourquoi le projet
vous suggère de créer une mesure
d'assignation à résidence qui constitue
une alternative à la rétention troisième
innovation enfin la directive retour
créé un dispositif d'interdiction de
retour qui est à portée européenne
cette mesure qui peut accompagner la
mesure d'éloignement est entouré de
nombreuses garanties
elle doit être motivé
elle n'a aucun caractère systématique et
l'autorité administrative peut t'on
moduler la durée
je rappelle enfin que dans une
résolution de février 2007 le sénat
s'était prononcé sur ce dispositif
indiquant que l'interdiction de retour
je cite constituerait un message fort de
solidarité européenne en matière de
lutte contre l'immigration illégale
par ailleurs le projet propose quelques
ajustements juridiques en matière
l'intégration et d'accès à la
nationalité
cela signifie d'abord faciliter l'accès
à la nationalité française aux étrangers
qui manifeste un parcours d'intégration
exceptionnement pour ces personnes qui
s'accomplissent dans les domaines
civique scientifique économique culturel
ou sportif
nous proposons de créer une voie d'accès
spécifique à la nationalité française
en réduisant la condition de résidence
de cinq à deux ans cela signifie ensuite
de s'assurer de l'adhésion aux valeurs
de tout étranger demandant à acquérir la
nationalité française
concrètement le postulants à la
naturalisation devra signer une charte
des droits et devoirs du citoyen
français
les parlementaires je le précise seront
dans l'esprit du gouvernement associer à
la rédaction de cette charte
en outre la maîtrise de notre langue
serait évalué de manière beaucoup plus
objective qu'aujourd'hui en s'inspirant
des référentiels linguistiques qui sont
en vigueur à l'échelon européen
je voudrais revenir sur un autre volet
du texte qui vous est soumis le
renforcement de l'efficacité de nos
procédures d'éloignement je pense
d'abord à la possibilité de créer en cas
de nécessité des zones d'attentes
temporaires faire cela c'est se préparer
à faire face à des situations
exceptionnelles pour que nos services
puissent agir dans un cadre clair
juridiquement précis plutôt que
d'improviser au milieu d'un vide
juridique
chacun se souvient que en janvier 2010
123 personnes d'origine kurde ont
débarqué de manière inopinée sur une
plage de corse du sud
ce dispositif nous aurait été très utile
il ne s'agit pas bien entendu de créer
un régime d'exception mais bien de
donner un cadre juridique clair celui
des zones d'attentes à des situations
exceptionnelles
la création de ces zones se fera dans le
respect de tous les droits dont
bénéficient habituellement les migrants
dans les zones d'attentes traditionnel
portuaires ou aéroportuaires
elle sera d'ailleurs limité dans le
temps a une durée maximale de 26 jours
que votre rapporteur a souhaité
introduire dans le texte je pense
ensuite à l'allongement de la durée
maximale de la rétention administrative
de 32 à 45 jours
cette mesure tient compte de deux
réalités première réalité la limite de
32 jours constitue un frein à la
conclusion des accords de réadmission
qui sont négociés au niveau
communautaire deuxième réalité
l'allongement de la durée maximale de
rétention administrative doit permettre
d'accroître le nombre de délivrance de
laissez passer consulaires en effet le
nombre de jours nécessaires à
l'obtention du laissez-passer consulaire
est souvent supérieur à 30 2 c'est le
cas par exemple de la chine pour
laquelle le délai moyen de délivrance du
document s'élève à 35 jours ou du mali
pour qui ce délai moyen de 38 jours
lorsque l'on sait que l'absence de
délivrance d'un laisser passer
consulaire représentent la première
cause d'échec des procédures
d'éloignement 34 % d'écart exactement
l'utilité de l'allongement de cette
durée maximale apparaît de façon claire
me semble-t-il
j'ajoute que cet allongement peut
paraître raisonnable puisque avec une
durée de 45 jours
la france conservera la durée de
rétention la plus faible d'europe depuis
que vous l'avez adopté en première
lecture le texte a évolué la principale
évolution du texte c'est que le
gouvernement a fait le choix de
privilégier
les mesures efficaces sur les mesures
symboliques c'est dans cet esprit que
nous avons accepté de ne plus faire
figurer la mesure sur la déchéance de
nationalité qui avait fait l'objet de
quelques critiques dans votre assemblée
elle n'était qu'une des 75 mesures
prévues par le projet de loi et ce choix
je crois est un signe s'il en était
besoin de l'attention que le
gouvernement apporte aux positions
exprimées par le sénat votre commission
des lois elle-même a apporté une
contribution tout à fait significatives
au texte en discussion je les dis le
travail mené conjointement entre le
gouvernement et votre rapporteur a
permis de dégager des positions communes
sur plusieurs sujets je pense aux
statuts des zones d'attentes temporaires
que j'évoquais à l'instant un
incrimination pénale du mariage fondée
sur une fraude aux sentiments ou encore
sur la lutte contre le travail des
étrangers sans titre
je voudrais également saluer la démarche
de votre président de la commission des
lois jean jacques hyest est de votre
rapporteur françois noël buffet qui ont
pris l'initiative de clarifier la
rédaction de l'article 17 ter sur les
étrangers malades
notre objectif est clair nous voulons
simplement éviter que l'assurance
maladie ne porte la responsabilité de
financer les carences des systèmes de
protection sociale des autres pays nous
voulons appliquer à la lettre la loi du
11 mai 81 18 mai nous récusons
l'interprétation qu'en a fait le conseil
d'état depuis avril 2010 je reconnais
toutefois que la rédaction qui vous
était proposé en première lecture était
sans doute ambiguë la rédaction qui est
proposée par votre rapporteur et le
président de votre commission des lois
est indiscutablement meilleur elle est
plus clair de surcroît elle fait une
ouverture en permettant à l'autorité
administrative de prendre en compte
des circonstances exceptionnelles et
humanitaire tirer de la situation
personnelle du demandeur pour décider
l'attribution du titre
même si les critères ne sont pas
remplies et je crois que c'est faire
oeuvre salutaire que d'ouvrir ainsi des
possibilités
l'attribution du titre je crois que nous
parvenons là un équilibre acceptable par
tous
et je dis d'emblée que le gouvernement
soutiendra l'amendement de messieurs y
est et buffet je voudrais pour terminer
vous dire quelques mots de la réforme du
contentieux de l'éloignement notre
commission des lois a validé le principe
de la réforme visant à rétablir l'ordre
logique des interventions respectives du
juge administratif et du juge judiciaire
je tiens à saluer cette position
cette réforme le gouvernement en est
convaincu est une bonne réforme
elle apportera plus de sécurité de
sécurité juridique une meilleure
administration de la justice
elle ne porte en aucune façon atteinte
au droit des étrangers
il demeure toutefois une nuance entre la
position du gouvernement et celle de
votre commission des lois celle ci
limite à quatre jours le délai
d'intervention du juge des libertés de
la détention
alors que le projet du gouvernement
prévoyait un délai de cinq jours
en réalité dans notre esprit ce délai
correspond au temps nécessaire pour que
le juge administratif puis se prononcer
sur le recours déposé par l'étranger
dans l'esprit du gouvernement les cinq
jours se décompose de la manière
suivante 48 heures pour que l'étranger
dépose son recours devant le juge
administratif et 72 heures pour que
celui ci statue
il y aurait donc deux manières de passer
de 5 jours à quatre jours première
option réduire de 24 heures le délai de
recours
mais cette option ne paraît pas
raisonnable car elles constitueraient un
retour
en arrière au détriment de l'expression
des droits des étrangers concernés elle
présenterait un fort risque
d'inconstitutionnalité de surcroît
puisque elle porterait atteinte au
principe du droit à un recours effectif
seconde option réduire de 24 heures le
temps imparti aux juges pour statuer qui
ne disposeraient alors plus de 72 heures
mais de 48
le gouvernement pense que cette
hypothèse n'est pas tout à fait
satisfaisante et pour plusieurs
compte tenu du volume du contentieux des
étrangers le respect du délai de 72
heures par les juges administratifs
nécessite déjà à l'heure actuelle des
efforts importants
or le projet de loi il faut bien avoir
conscience de façon mécanique va
accroître le nombre de recours devant le
juge administratif
à partir du moment où il sera le premier
juge appelé à se prononcer il est
inévitable que davantage d'étrangers
souhaiteront le solliciter aujourd'hui
seule une mesure d'éloignement sur six
est contestée devant le juge
administratif
probablement parce que beaucoup
d'étrangers anticipe qu'ils seront
d'abord présenté au juge des libertés et
de la détention et que ce donc devant ce
juge qu'ils doivent faire valoir leurs
arguments
en outre avec le projet de loi le juge
administratif est le seul juge compétent
pour contrôler des innovations
l'interdiction de recours est une voie
de recours accéléré et crée devant lui
sur la légalité du placement en
rétention
tout cela doit normalement conduire les
étrangers à saisir plus fréquemment le
juge administratif en outre chacune de
ces requêtes sera elle-même plus
complexe à juger de cela aussi il faut
avoir conscience car elle portera sur un
nombre plus élevé qu'auparavant de
décisions administratives
le projet de loi crée l'interdiction de
retour impose aux préfets de prendre une
décision sur l'octroi ou non du délai de
départ volontaire et amène le juge à se
prononcer plus systématiquement sur la
légalité du placement en rétention
au total le juge administratif n'aura
pas moins de cinq d'édition
administrative a jugé
lorsqu'il sera saisie il lui sera donc
très difficile de se prononcer en 48
heures au lieu des 72 actuelle le juge
risques dans ces conditions de se
prononcer hors délai ce qui réduirait à
néant notre stratégie visant à ce qu'il
soit tu avant le juge judiciaire
je me permets d'ajouter une autre
considération qui est très pratique
réduire le délai de jugement à 48 heures
cela revient pour un recours déposé le
vendredi à imposer de statuer
pendant le week-end cela n'est pas
forcément très facile à faire
fonctionner la justice dans des
conditions serait de même système les
quatre jours pose d'autres questions
d'organisation qui sont très concrètes
mais très difficile compte tenu d'un
délai de jugement très contraint le
tribunal organe administratif
organiserait son audience
quelques heures seulement avant que le
juge des libertés et de la détention
organise lui-même son audience
si les deux juges ne siège pas dans la
même ville
ce sera très difficile de présenter
d'étrangers dans des conditions
matériellement satisfaisante
devant ces deux juges administratifs et
judiciaires
c'est pour toutes ces raisons que les
vice-présidents du conseil d'état
successifs se sont explicitement
prononcé en leur qualité de président du
conseil supérieur des tribunaux
administratifs je le précise et non par
leur qualité juridictionnelle en 2003 et
en 2006 pour un délai de jugement de 72
heures je voudrais aussi souligner que
le report à cinq jours de l'intervention
du jld ne constitue pas une atteinte
excessive au droit de l'étranger à être
présenté à un juge
même après la réforme la france n'aurait
rien à envier en termes de droit des
étrangers
un recours effectif à ses principaux
partenaires faut bien sûr limiter les
comparaisons au pays qui comme la france
ont un système de dualisme
juridictionnelle mais nous
évoquons sans doute ces questions dans
le courant des débats vraiment la france
continuera à se présenter dans
d'excellentes conditions
par rapport à ce partenaire bref vous
l'avez compris aux yeux du gouvernement
le report à cinq jours de l'intervention
du juge des libertés et de la détention
constitue une réforme proportionnée aux
objectifs poursuivis qui sont de
renforcer la sécurité juridique des
procédures et d'assurer une meilleure
administration de la justice
et c'est cette option que le
gouvernement vous demande de bien
vouloir retenir
voilà madame la présidente monsieur le
président des commissions des lois
monsieur le rapporteur mesdames et
messieurs les sénateurs ce que je
souhaitais partager avec vous cet après
midi avec ce projet de loi le
gouvernement un objectif simple et clair
apporter des réponses républicaines
concrètes opérationnelles aux défis
auxquels est confronté aujourd'hui notre
politique d'immigration car nous n'avons
qu'une ambition mener une politique
d'immigration ferme à l'endroit de
celles et de ceux qui ne respectent pas
la loi de la république mais aussi
humaine c'est-à-dire respectueuse des
droits et de la dignité des personnes et
accueillante pour les étrangers que nous
autorisons à ces journées c'est à cette
condition que nous parviendrons à
consolider l'équilibré de notre
communauté et notre cohésion sociale je
vous remercie
merci ministre 1 la parole est à
monsieur françois noël buffet rapporteur
de la commission des lois
chercher
même le président monsieur le ministre
mes chers collègues nous abordons
effectivement aujourd'hui la deuxième
lecture du projet de loi relatif à
l'immigration l'intégration et à la
nationalité qui nous a été transmis par
nos collègues de l'assemblée nationale
le 15 mars dernier
je vous propose d'abord d'évoquer en
quelques mots les points sur lesquels
nous sommes parvenus à ce stade avec
l'assemblée nationale à un accord je
dois y est qu'ils sont ces accords sont
nombreux et concernent quelques-uns des
aspects essentiels de la réforme
tout d'abord la transposition des
mesures d'éloignement prévues par la
directive du 16 décembre 2008 relative
aux normes et procédures communes
applicables dans les états membres
au retour des ressortissants de pays
tiers en séjour irrégulier dite
directive retour a fait l'objet d'un
accord entre nos deux assemblées
rappelons rappelons qu elle substitue au
dispositif actuellement existants en
matière d'éloignement des étrangers en
situation irrégulière
une mesure unique d'obligation de
quitter le territoire
communément dénommé au cul tfc taux du
tf sera dans chaque cas assortis ou non
d'un délai de départ volontaire selon
des critères précis dont la commission
des lois du sénat a souhaité qu'il soit
énuméré de manière limitative
comme d'ailleurs nous l'avions décidé en
première lecture
je pense que la simplification apportés
par cette réforme est une bonne chose
tant pour nos administrations qui se
voit actuellement confronté à des choix
difficiles du seul fait d'un manque de
clarté des dispositions du code des
étrangers que pour les citoyens et pour
les étrangers eux mêmes qui seront ainsi
mieux à même de comprendre le sens et la
portée des décisions qui seront prises à
leur encontre
je note par ailleurs que les députés ont
accepté de revenir comme nous l'avions
souhaité à une interdiction de retour
non automatique mais décidée par le
préfet en tenant compte de manière
approfondie de la situation personnelle
de l'étranger et de ses liens éventuels
avec notre pays nous deux assemblées ont
également trouvé un accord sur les
dispositions introduites par le
gouvernement pour assurer une
transposition plus fidèles de la
directive dite libre circulation il sera
désormais écrit expressément dans le
code des étrangers que seule une menace
réelle actuelle est suffisamment grave
pour un intérêt fondamental de la
société pourra justifier qu'un
ressortissant communautaire sont
éloignés de notre territoire
il est également précisé que l'autorité
administrative devra tenir le plus grand
compte de la situation de l'intéressé
avant de prononcer une telle mesure
voilà qui donne aux points de vue
devrait enfin apaisé le débat relatifs
aux garanties dont bénéficierait ou ne
bénéficierait pas les ressortissants
bulgares ou roumains
nous avons par ailleurs trouvé un accord
sur une partie du dispositif relatif aux
zones d'attentes dit haddock
celles ci permettront de prendre en
charge dans de bonnes conditions
des arrivées de groupes de personnes en
dehors des points de passage frontaliers
en les faisant bénéficier et des droits
afférents aux zones d'attentes dite
ordinaire restent cependant sur ce sujet
quelques points de divergence avec
l'assemblée nationale que nous évoquons
dans quelques instants sur les
dispositions destinées à renforcer les
conditions dans lesquelles la simulation
de l'étranger à la communauté française
est appréciée les députés ont en seconde
lecture ajouter des éléments relatifs à
l'évaluation de la connaissance de
l'histoire de la culture et de la
société française
la commission des lois a inséré des
précisions indispensables nous
semble-t-il pour assurer la plus grande
équité entre les personnes en
particulier il est nécessaire que les
connaissances continue à être appréciée
comme le prévoit le code civil selon la
condition de chaque personne qui demande
à être naturalisés s'agissant par
ailleurs de la disposition très débattue
relatives à la déchéance de la
nationalité
l'assemblée nationale qui avait adopté
cette disposition en première lecture
s'est rallié en seconde lecture à la
position du sénat qu'il avait supprimé
en séance publique
un dernier point sur lequel je retient
notre attention tout la plupart des
dispositions relatives à la législation
du travail et aux poursuites contre les
travailleurs n'ont pas les travailleurs
illégaux mais les entrepreneurs qui
emploie des personnes dans le cas des
travail illégal font partie des points
d'accord à quelques exceptions près il
faut d'ailleurs surgir réjouir que de
nos travaux sur ce sujet se soit déroulé
de manière relativement consensuelle
voilà pour les points d'accord j'en
viens maintenant au point de discussion
qui restent pendants et qui quels sont
donc les principaux sujets sur lesquels
nous avons exprimé un désaccord avec les
travaux de l'assemblée nationale je
voudrais une fois mais ça n'est pas
l'usagé peut-être à ces tribunes mais
faire une toute petite mise au point qui
me paraît importante pour le sénat je
veux dire que je regrette que nos
collègues députés et souvent rejetées
sans explication aucune
sans explication aucune des
modifications que nous avions apporté
dans le seul souci d'améliorer le texte
qui nous étaient soumis mais je regrette
encore plus je regrette encore plus que
opposé nos travaux à ceux dits de entre
les parenthèses la représentation
nationale comme l'a fait à plusieurs
reprises le rapporteur de l'assemblée
nationale ne me semble pas tout à fait
digne de l'esprit du bicamérisme qui
nous anime
après tout après tout
après tout nous sommes tous élus au
suffrage universel il fallait le dire
les jeunes dirais c'est faire pour en
venir à revenir au texte
nous avons d'abord estimé qu'il
convenait de mieux définir les zones
d'attentes haddock
en effet le texte issu de l'assemblée
nationale permettrait de créer des zones
d'attentes haddock à caractère pérenne
ce qui ne correspond pas ni à
l'intention initiale du gouvernement ni
à l'idée que l'on peut se faire d'un
dispositif temporaire destiné à répondre
à des situations exceptionnelles
la commission a donc adopté un
amendement qui permet de préserver ce
caractère exceptionnel dispositif en
fixant une
durée maximale de 26 jours correspondant
à celle du maintien en zone d'attenté
ordinaire par ailleurs l'assemblée
adopté en séance publique un amendement
supprimant le principe de l'acquisition
automatique de la nationalité française
à 18 ans pour les enfants nés en france
de parents étrangers ayant leur
résidence habituelle en france sans
avoir à se prononcer sur le fond une
telle disposition qui constitue une
mesure nouvelle sans lien direct avec
une disposition du texte en discussion
puisqu'elle concerne l'acquisition
automatique de la nationalité française
et non la naturalisation ou
l'acquisition par déclaration ne
satisfait pas à la règle de l'entonnoir
est présente pour cette raison un
véritable risque d'inconstitutionnalité
dura lex sed lex mais c'est pourquoi
votre commission l'a écarté la
commission également rejeté la
modification des dispositions en vigueur
relative au séjour des étrangers
gravement malades
la volonté de revenir à l'état antérieur
à la une jurisprudence excessivement qui
nous paraissent excessivement libéral du
conseil d'état sans toutefois sans
toutefois les études c'est la raison
pour laquelle comme le ministre monsieur
miss vous l'avez rappelé il ya quelques
instants
la commission a adopté un amendement ce
matin visant à rédiger de nouveaux
l'article 17 ter en fixant bien les
objectifs qui sont souhaitées par les
uns et par les autres à savoir tout en
tenant à la volonté d'avoir une action à
caractère humanitaire et en préservant
bien sûr sur notre territoire ce qui
sont des étrangers qui sont les plus
gravement malade pouvoir tout de même
affirmer un principe de fermeté afin de
ne pas avoir à gérer un certain nombre
de déviance du dispositif concernant
l'immigration démaria l'incrimination
pardon des mariages gris les députés
n'ont pas suivi senna qui avait remplacé
celui ci dans le cadre du droit et de
l'échelle des peines en vigueur la
commission a rétabli la rédaction votée
par le sénat en première lecture
s'agissant du droit d'asile notre
commission a exprimé son désaccord
également international sur un certain
nombre de dispositions ce droit
constitue une tente une tradition
nationale qu'une obligations
constitutionnelles et conventionnelles
il faut par conséquent en préserver son
efficacité son effectivité pardon c'est
pourquoi la commission a à nouveau est à
nouveau revenu sur la suppression pure
et simple de l'aide juridictionnelle en
procédure de réexamen de manière à ce
que seules soient concernées les
personnes qui ont pu faire leur demande
dans de bonnes conditions
c'est à dire après avoir été
précédemment entendu par l'ofpra ainsi
que par la cour nationale du droit
d'asile
assisté par un avocat désigné au titre
de lady di sierre enfin enfin et surtout
le débat reste ouvert sur la difficile
question du contentieux des mesures
d'éloignement
au delà de cinq jours pour au délai de
cinq jours pardon pour l'intervention du
juge des libertés et de la détention
saisi par le préfet pour prolonger la
rétention administrative la commission
des lois a préféré sur proposition de
notre président jean jacques hyest un
délai de quatre jours
bien que ce délai n'est pas été
expressément validée par le conseil
constitutionnel
il semble en effet déjà en vigueur ce
délai est en effet déjà en vigueur
pardon dans les ports et zones
d'attentes le risque de censure sont
donc le moindre d'autant que la
commission vous proposera également de
prévoir que le juge administratif doit
se prononcent doivent se prononcer sur
les décisions prises par le préfet à
l'encontre de l'étranger dans le même
délai de quatre jours sera ainsi
préservé l'objectif de clarification des
procédures juridictionnelles absolument
nécessaire comme l'avait redit le
rapport mazeaud qui constitue le sens
même d'ailleurs de cette réforme
voici mes chers collègues les grands
axes de modifications adoptées par la
commission des lois pour la seconde
lecture de ce projet et c'est donc en
l'état qu'il se présente à nous merci
icha collègues dans la suite de la
discussion générale la parole est à
monsieur jean louis masson au titre des
non-inscrits
comme le président monsieur le ministre
chers collègues ce projet de loi qui
concerne les conditions de séjour qui
est d'ailleurs très large est un projet
de loi qui conduit à répondre à porter à
se rendre de réponse à des vrais
problèmes
ceci étant je regrette très vivement que
sur certains points il n'a y pas assez
loin parce que à mon avis et de la vie
quand même de beaucoup de nos
concitoyens
les problèmes de l'immigration sont
pause disons à l'ensemble de notre
société un certain nombre de difficultés
à s'entendre de deux pros de problèmes
qui amène nos concitoyens a souhaité que
tout moment un certain nombre de nos
concitoyens dont je fais partie a
souhaité qu'il y ait une plus grande
fermeté et je crois que les les récents
résultats des élections sur les
cantonales ou d'autres élections
montrent que nos citoyens qui se lève
tous les matins pour aller travailler et
c'est bien souhaiterait qu'à un moment
donné
la société française tiennent compte
avant tout des problèmes des gens qui
habitent en france plus que des
problèmes des gens qui veulent venir qui
malgré nos loire veulent venir sur le
territoire français donc pour ma part
certaines de ses dispositions me
paraissent pertinentes
par contre je ne suis pas tout à fait
d'accord sur l'esprit qui a prévalu à
eau le disons à cette loi face aux dix
ans au dépôt de ce projet de loi parce
que on assiste actuellement à une sorte
d' instrumentalisation à des fins
politiques ou politiciennes d'un certain
nombre de dossiers de problèmes qui
mériterait d'être traités plus
sérieusement que ce soit plus
furieusement dans le sens de
l'assouplissement plus sérieusement dans
le sens du durcissement quand je le
souhaite
on a à peu près chaque année un ou deux
textes sur la délinquance sur
l'immigration et caetera et je pense que
nous
concitoyens commence en avoir par dessus
la tête parce que quand il y a des
vraies difficultés et bien on sort un
lapin du chapeau en dix ans maintient on
va lancer une idée est le meilleur
exemple de lapin du chapeau c'est est ce
cette déchéance de la nationalité
française
bon ça servait strictement à rien mais
on esquel lapin pour faire croire à nos
citoyens qu'on faisait quelque chose
alors au lieu de secouer le lapin de la
déchéance de la nationalité française
qui n'aurait concerné peut-être qu'une
ou deux personnes tous les tous les dix
ans ou tous les tous les cinq ans il
valait mieux peut-être prendre des
mesures un peu plus coercitives
alors je crois que là c'est tout
problème d'ailleurs qui est posée de
l'action du gouvernement et du priant la
république depuis quelques années parce
que on assiste parfois au dévoiement de
problèmes de fond qui mériterait d'être
traités sur des règles de fond sur une
base de fonds 1 et qui sont
systématiquement instrumentalisée sur
dans une logique politicienne et pour ma
part je le dis bien je suis partisan
d'un durcissement de la loi sur tout ce
qui concerne l'immigration et dans un
certain nombre de dossiers
par contre je suis radicalement hostile
à ces gesticulations politiciennes
auquel on assiste continuellement au
niveau de la gestion de la france
actuellement
et d'ailleurs le résultat des dernières
élections cantonales devrait faire
réfléchir à certains nombre de personnes
et au plus haut niveau de l'état
merci chers collègues la parole est à
madame anne marie escoffier pour le
groupe du rassemblement démocratique
social européen
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues il n'y a
aucune raison pour que la mondialisation
croissante d échanger de l'information
ne s'étende pas aux mouvements de
population s'ils sont maîtriser les flux
migratoires seront une richesse pour
notre pays
d'ailleurs la france a toujours été un
pays d'immigration et elle doit à cette
tradition une large part de son regret
dans l'hémicycle du sénat merci à vous
d'avoir suivi cette séance si vous
souhaitez la revoir notre site internet
public sénat point fr à suivre le
journal de 19h présenté ce soir par
michel grossiord il reviendra bien
entendu sur l'examen de ce projet de loi
immigration intégration et nationalité
très bonne soirée à tous sur public
sénat